good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast stand happy
Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday everybody's
looking forward to the weekend weekend
Friday Friday getting down on Friday
that's right it's Friday it's Friday
it's Friday it is the end of the week
Bruno's in studio Jackson Claude are
finally back together oh my God they
tried to keep us apart this week
everyone well we were technically
together on Wednesday
we literally never even got to rank out
my special like not to make Friday about
me but like we were together here Monday
Tuesday Wednesday I took the day off and
we had dumois a totally different person
a different person than Claudia there's
nothing in common between the two even
though they both talked about SVU John
Mayer and how funny Claudia is we did
but that just goes to prove that like
powerful women all have that in common
it's called a coincidence and I heard
one said a coincidence is God's way of
staying Anonymous it's also Dumas way of
staying I never heard that yeah isn't
that nice cute I read it I think cute
it's literally a coincidence
um and then Thursday yesterday I woke up
in a tizzy Harry had to go to the doctor
counts stood in she did a great job by
the way people were living did I was
listening on our way to our photo shoot
uh we did a shoot yeah because we're
models and we do photo shoots you guys
because everybody wants us to be the
face of their brand what can we say
absolutely everyone and it it did I kind
of realized something yesterday and I I
want to preface this by saying I
realized that absolutely nobody's
offering me this job but the way I would
never want to be a model like we were
just on set for so long and like most of
being a model is like waiting around for
everything to be ready you know yeah and
then like being in uncomfortable
positions and like being like does this
look good I can't see and everyone's
yelling at me and telling me that I
don't look good also I think the worst
part about being a model is that it's
not an easy job whatsoever but nobody
feels bad nobody respects you nobody
feels bad for you ever ever No you can
set offset if you want to be like my job
like I was modeling really hard today
like I'm sure you were Bella I'm sure
you were you know yeah so Justice for
the models honestly no just as for the
fellow models for the fellow models and
the coal miners and the coal miners um
also Justice for Ariel charnis which is
something we're really gonna get into
today we've been talking about this all
week kind of being at the center of this
story not to make like her life about us
um but Jackie and I you know we have we
have a dream and a printer so we have
this we have the charmness file the
20-page article that we was so dumb and
so um really poorly written and so over
hyped we have printed it it was behind a
paywall so we'll give you all the
details you need to know so you don't
have to pay that one dollar for the
trial it's not worth it and I don't feel
like we should be financially supporting
poor Journal yellow we shouldn't be
financially supporting muckrakers no not
at all you guys this is 20 pages of
nothing Burger Mist so if you were
hungry you're gonna stay hungry because
there's nothing here except for Business
Insider exposing themselves and we have
to get into all the details because
there are a lot of details some that are
like interesting some that are just like
relatable influencer things and things
that actually made me laugh out loud
yeah no there's a lot to discuss there's
a lot to discuss but overall like the
Arc of this week has been Justice for
aerial charm it's like I can't believe
the level the roller coaster like the
the fever pitch that things reached like
the embezzling four to five million
dollars according to do one no totally
secret sex club multiple partners I've
never been with multiple partners in my
life it's all coming out this week and
then we got this piece of Duty that
basically said that Ariel charnis's
brand is maybe not as successful as they
would have hoped it is you know and it's
like we're so
so but like uh are you like living in
the same economy that we all are like
why are you surprised Business Insider
aren't you a business publication are
you aware that we're in a recession and
that retail is just not what it once was
yeah my takeaway from this article was
that Ariel charnis is an American and
She's suffering just like the rest of us
okay economic turmoil dark Economic
Times yeah okay there's so much to get
into and we will get into it there's
also just great stories catching up with
Jax how has your week been in New York
it's almost over it's not been the week
that I had planned no
um it's been extremely exhausting and
I'm looking forward to going home I know
it's just been a lot with Harry was
really really sick and he's doing better
it's just like it's I would rather him
be sick at home and we could have like
everything we need and I know no and
then it's like instead of like trying to
order overnight everything from Amazon
and then like you came to town for all
these fabulous Tings the toast tbg
Awards how are you sick couldn't go yeah
and we had like fun things planned for
Harry because it's such a fun time of
year in New York and like nothing
happened no I know but I did get good
work stuff done like it was good doing
the toast together we did have this
photo shoot because we are models I got
to see your special taping and I got to
do the toast with do even though
technically I could have done it from
Florida you got to do with my best
friend to do you and do are like best
friends now texting mwah
yeah honestly the episode was really fun
so that was like a fun treat but I
technically we did it over basically so
I could have done that from home uh
but other than that yeah it was just not
what you know what but man plans God
laughs so true so with six season out
there and that's just what happens yeah
no everyone wash your hands like
you're disgusting no but like it's
that's just it's hard for the course
it's flu season like it's I'm really
hoping RSV season I'm really hoping I
don't get sick
but like if you did
so you get sick and it's part of life no
I know but like the thing about me is
like I'm just
um a complaining annoying person yes how
did you know and you just like can't
stand to feel off slightly
inconvenienced like but you get to be in
bed when you're sick so true and you
could read and watch TV and Ben has to
bring everything which is so different
so different because I'm never in bed
and Ben never brings you stuff no no
never it's actually one of my biggest
gripes with him and I feel like you
don't like being sick because like you
don't like soup
I literally hate soup I think it's
it's you know what if God is staying
Anonymous with his coincidences with
soup he's literally making you drink
kazira and like I think soup is so
disgusting and the annoying thing about
it is like it really makes you feel
better yeah it does like I'll never
forget I like recently I had strep so
bad and after like four days like I
finally drank soup and when I tell you
my throat instantly felt completely fine
that's so funny if you had to have soup
what's your favorite kind chicken noodle
like with all the Schmutz like give me a
matzo ball give me chicken give me pasta
so I could like eat everything yeah give
me everything inside so like I can eat
the meat and not the soup but you make
the broth soup via the sponge of the
matzo ball right the broth is what
really it is truly penicillin Jewish
penicillin
but I hate it like I hate soup and
there's no tea
there's not another kind of soup that
you like
I don't even want to say this because I
know the answer lentil no French onion I
guess butternut squash another soup that
I kind of like is when my ice cream's
all melted and I can slurp it that's
really good especially if there's like
sprinkles in there a little crunch no
but that's not good for your throat no
dairy's not good for your throat
produces mucus yeah yeah no I have like
a lot of throat problems because I'm a
30 almost 30 year old woman with tonsils
I actually woke up this morning and my
throat it feel like I'm okay if my
throat usually is at 100 like today it's
at like 85 so that's just the beginning
of probably me getting what's been going
around but I'm just grateful that I
didn't get it while you were aware and
wasn't able to not take care of Harry or
work so if I go home and I'm sick then
next week if you guys if I drop off you
know there will come a day because I'm
like very nervous about getting surgery
but there's a few surgeries that I
absolutely need to get and there will be
a day when I would just walk into New
York Presbyterian Hospital have them put
me under and get myself my tonsils taken
out probably my wisdom teeth too a
breast reduction liposuction
um maybe a facelift like I will do it
all in one and I'll be out of commission
for probably a month there'll be no
toast but one day like I will get all
the surgeries that I need but I'll get
them done in one foul swoop and there
will be no toast and that's kind of why
I've been pushing it off yeah because I
work so hard yeah even though like
there's a lot of problems with
everything you just stated but sure what
do you mean like what you're gonna have
the dentist there working on your wisdom
teeth while the plastic surgeons there
working on your breasts and all these
other plastic surgeon down working on my
fupa yeah liposuction is
it's not you it's like outpatient
it's not it's not there are outpatient
liposuctions but like for what the
procedure I need to have done I'm going
to be fully under and I'll have three or
four doctors working at me at the same
time okay we hopefully get they get
along they don't start they all standing
there with knives I just need a really
really good anesthesiologist just to
make sure like you know I'm like nervous
and this is you should have Dr Tiffany
Moon totally you can add this to my
favorite stories like why I'm afraid of
anesthesia Nip Tuck yeah that episode
yeah add it to the list that episode and
you can also add Ariel charnis being a
covidia to my favorite stories list
because that's a hill I'm certainly
willing to die on yeah um yeah that is
one of my favorite stories and one of
the reasons why I'm like afraid to get
my tonsils taken out is because that
episode of nip talk where that girl has
like this very adverse reaction to
Anesthesia
anesthesia anesthesia
I know anesthetic no no but what's the
word anesthesia anesthesia anesthesia
anesthesia Romanov Anastasia
Romanov okay whatever to the anesthetic
organist where she's awake the whole
time but physically paralyzed so she
feels hears and sees everything and then
when I first started dating Ben and we
went to like his extended families for
the first time one of his cousins is an
anesthesiologist and you know when
you're meeting a family for the first
time you're always like looking for
something to talk about so I figured
common ground with anesthesiologist
would be this episode and I was ready
for him to like make me feel better he's
like well it is like an urban legend but
it's not entirely impossible yeah I
don't know if I've asked you this but on
the episode was the patient of redhead
yes how do you know that because
redheads have a high or like a higher
tolerance for anesthesia if you're a
natural redhead and you're going under
like they need to know she was a redhead
so you don't have to worry about it I do
oh plot twists not you stealing my story
stealing your fear wait yes she was
redhead yeah it's a redhead thing I'm
shook I feel like we've had this
conversation before it's feeling
familiar yeah I feel like we have and I
feel like I've told you that redheads
are like special in the a negative way
when it comes down to seating you like
just don't care and you just keep making
it about you and like you never think
about me no I never think about you and
you know who else is a redhead Bryson
streiss it's true
God okay well I'm glad we settled that
like when Theo went under for his teeth
cleaning today it was a very special
like fancy um anesthesiologist on set
i'm set on on the floor in the room
um
what's it called No it's like there's a
word it's like in the orchestra
but there's like a really nice operating
word for when you're in the operating
room it's like Orchestra or something
like that yeah no no it's an itch I must
scratch oh you brought your iPad today
even though everyone's like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] talk about her real Journeys
yeah no we will talk about Ariel charnis
and you're gonna be begging us to stop
when theater
for surgery hold on let me just confirm
you'll be fine an operating theater also
known as the operating room didn't that
feel good guys not really felt good for
me now I can move on
um we will talk about Ariel sharpness we
will talk about the new Beauty and the
Beast remake we will be talking about
Taylor Swift's directorial debut there's
much to discuss there's actually trash
[ __ ] stories yesterday and I
don't know if you listen to the whole
episode but like did you feel my call
about like Margot like what is part of
like in pop culture I understood what
you meant
um to a degree but I also understood by
Margaret was like are you kidding me
because also she's constantly like going
so hard for the things that she loves
like on her Instagram and stuff like
it's very clear what she loves I know
but no what she loves like wasn't a
story about honestly It's upsetting that
she didn't host today because there's a
story today about Zac Brown from Zac
Brown Band yeah no that's what she would
give a [ __ ] about like I don't like I
really couldn't pinpoint what her
interests are in public she doesn't care
about Whoopi Goldberg not wanting
posture movies made thank you yeah thank
you and it's not like she cares so much
about like Charlie demilio it's not
because she's young it's just because
she's specific yeah but we had a great
time and actually The Toasters really
came to Marco's defense about
um referencing the state of Pennsylvania
as PA that's like a thing normal people
do and all the toasters from PA were
like no literally everyone says that so
Margaret was justified in saying that
and the man on her date was just a dick
where was where in PA was he from I
don't know I didn't ask because I feel
like if he was some like Philly or like
the surrounding suburbs like they don't
call it people it's like because
Rebecca's from technically Pennsylvania
PA but she's never called it that but
that's just because she's not from real
PA right that's actually a really good
call maybe it's like a
county by county moment yeah and he was
exposing himself as just being so
insular and living in a bubble yeah not
you thinking small
couldn't be you
um I feel like we should just get into
it like we absolutely like I have not
been able to think of anything but
aerial Chinese and when I tell you
literally I love that like you know we
have established ourselves both you know
in the world and also in our personal
lives as experts on everything that goes
on on the internet when I tell you like
I thought I've been thinking so much
about Chinese we've been talking about
on the podcast like every single person
has been texting me like what do you
know like some like influencers friends
from real life like what's going on and
it's like I have to explain to everyone
just because I feel Justified like I
feel defensive like I need people to
think like everything you've heard about
Ariel turns is not true right so
normally people text me like I'm not
gonna answer I would be like honestly I
can't even talk you should have like a
set blurb ready to go and then after
today can you just send them this
episode right because like all the
things that were said like people
probably didn't follow up with the
article and just assumed like yeah he
was embezzling and they are getting
divorced and that that ain't right
because that's like actually someone's
life yeah so the headline here is that
everything all of the rumors that we're
circulating this week about Ariel
tardness are not true
and the article that was being written
is really honestly it's there's for me
there's nothing in there that's actually
newsworthy that was my major takeaway
from this whole Saga there were two
takeaways one is like this article like
I'm not really sure what the point was
because it's just like her business is
not doing well
um and that's for a variety of reasons
I'm sure the economy has a lot to do
with it I'm sure maybe poor management
has to do with it whatever the reason is
the company's not doing well and I don't
know that there's an article written
every time a company doesn't do well
it's company it's not like her company
like went under it and nobody knew it's
like they're having a bad quarter like
are you gonna write about every company
that's not right so I didn't understand
how that was not happy with their
results this quarter that was my
takeaway and then my other takeaway is
just like the general
um Behavior the Glee not even the Glee
just like this is really it can be a
case study on like how damaging
Anonymous gossip is and how forums like
Reddit are actually so damaging and so
dumb and so full of lies and people
really need to adjust how they regard
information that they find out on the
internet because it's [ __ ] not true
yeah I feel like until you experience
the cycle love like seeing something
that you know is like categorically
false
um then until that happens and that
happened for everyone here today so
hopefully it's a watershed moment until
that happens like you read something
you're like we're there smoke there's
fire and then also like do what did give
like an air of legitimacy to some of
these claims because like she is the
go-to source for a lot of things so I
wonder what she's thinking after last
night like either she doesn't usually
talk about influencers and now she's
like wishing she didn't right either you
know the people who were writing into
her don't know [ __ ] about [ __ ] or you
know Business Insider could improve some
of these allegations uh so they left it
out so they and it just
I don't know the Business Insider is
like known to be like really shady with
their like journalism so I feel like if
there were allegations that had like a
little bit of proof on but not like
fully like they don't care like they put
[ __ ] out all the time that's like
fraudulent like they're known to be like
the article like so and so said
something really [ __ ] nasty but we
couldn't verify it like but it's out
there then so if there was so and so
said that Brandon harness embezzled and
that's how he's paying for their life a
lot like that would have been a
paragraph right no and it's like the the
pull quote that everyone's taking is
like
Ariel charnis is the Bernie Madoff of
the fashion industry like as if like a
million people said that and it was like
one disgruntled vendor said it and so to
make a blanket statement and like that's
like the pull quote that's all over
Twitter like I just feel like this
article is so unnecessarily like
targeting and intentionally trying to
damage
oh an already damaged business no and
like do you not know what Bernie Madoff
did right like because if you knew then
that's just like a bad comparison no
then it's just kind of insensitive it's
a bad metaphor yeah so let's get into it
and the Fast Five it's gonna be it's
gonna be a great day here because you
know what I smell
Justice I smell Justice and you know
what it smells like heaven yep without
further adieu here are the past five
stories that you need to know and
today's episode is brought to you by
Kitsch when did Beauty get so
complicated so much time too much money
and not enough products that will that
work for you and that's why kit was
created to simplify self-care and beauty
products that give you a major boost so
you can go on to your next thing Kitsch
offers game-changing time-saving Beauty
Essentials for Hair Skin and Body
whatever your budget your skin type your
hair type kids believes that you deserve
little indulgences and affordable prices
morning noon and night so their best
sellers at kitch include satin
pillowcases eye masks and caps which if
you are a rough sleeper like myself and
you wake up with hair that might as well
have not been done the night before
really think about getting satin hair
accessory series it'll make a huge
difference in how you wake up they also
have shampoo and conditioner bars which
are all part of bottle-free beauty
heatless satin curl rollers went viral
on Tick Tock I've got them they
genuinely work you can reduce the heat
damage to your hair and their classic
hair ties and scrunchies so kitchen is
your One Stop Shop for all your holiday
gifting your family your besties and all
the resties who deserve a little
something special this year right now
kitch is offering discounts site-wide
anywhere from 25 off all the way to 60
off all of the month of November when
you go to mykitch.com toast you heard it
here first at first that's discounts up
to 60 off certain items at mykitch
m-y-k-i-t-s-c-h.com slash toast plus
kitchens daily flash shells unbelievable
deals so check back often one more time
that's mykitch.com toast for huge
holiday discounts everything you need
for Holiday gifting or treating yourself
also check out their claw Clips if
you've got like big thick hair and your
hair doesn't fit in claw Clips the ones
from Kitsch are really stellar and they
will fit your entire hair today's
episode is also brought to you by
manscaped it must be a holiday Miracle
because the sponsor of today's show
manscaped are stuffing your stockings
with everything you need in your life
and everything you could ask for that's
right this holiday season manscaped has
vowed to make sure that your man's
ornaments are shining bright and his
tree is Standing Tall spice up his
stocking with gifts will actually use
and something that you can enjoy too if
you don't believe in Santa you better
believe in this they've changed seven
million men for the better and you can
get 20 off in free shipping by going to
manscaped.com toast manscaped
best-selling products are the
performance package 4.0 which is at the
top of every man's wish list this year
Ben has it he's had it for a while it is
his favorite thing by far it has
everything inside that you could
possibly need the lawnmower body trimmer
the best trimmer on the market for balls
back chest the list goes on the weed
whacker which is an ear and nose hair
trimmer which is really more for the
lady than for the man but we all win
nonetheless and their famous liquid
formula is like the crop preserver ball
deodorant a crop reviver ball toner
it'll keep him smelling nice down there
and they're the perfect fit for any
stocking
if you want to save 20 off and free
shipping go to manscaped.com toast
twenty percent off and free shipping at
manscaped.com toast cheers to rocking
the best gifts this holiday season a
gift for him but really a gift for you
again that's manscaped.com toast make
sure you hurry up to their site and
ensure that these gifts show up before
the holiday season and make sure you're
using the 20 off and free shipping at
manscaped.com toast whether this is for
your partner your dad or your brother
your friend get them something they will
actually use and it's almost sure to get
a laugh after all who doesn't like
opening a ball deodorant under the
Christmas tree I truly think that's what
Santa wanted I really do honestly santa
wants antenna needs manscape yeah I
heard Santa has smelly balls but you
didn't hear it for me yeah
I heard Santa like uses manscape when he
can find the time because Mrs Claus is
like that smelly Gooch out of here no
Mrs Claus runs a tight chat ship
on some days except she couldn't get her
disgruntled employees in check Arielle
charnis you guys our first story of the
day is the story on everybody's lips
The Business Insider article that has
been a rumor to drop this week has
finally dropped and the headline is
Ariel charnis's company something Navy
is floundering amid dwindling sales and
employee Exodus and Furious suppliers so
when this article first came out I saw
the headline I was like I knew it I knew
like everyone was talking about
literally nothing that's what I was
saying on the toast yesterday I'm like
we're all getting so bent out of shape
and there's no article yet so like once
the article comes out and everything is
in there we can while out right but
until then like we all need to seriously
calm the [ __ ] down and given the rumors
that we heard this week like the
headline would have been of course
his husband Brandon is arrested at polar
bar in Miami right
um amid a measlement claims four to five
million dollars and they're getting
divorced so the second I saw this
headline I was like oh my God big
nothing burger and you know what if you
had asked me like a week ago how do you
think that something Navy's like
clothing companies doing I probably
would have said like not great I'm
always getting targeted Facebook ads for
it and like honestly this stuff isn't my
style
um and it just didn't pop off in the way
that like maybe it could have so I I
think I could have told you that like
it's not that successful which isn't a
crime and it's not that big of a deal
especially because what I thought was
actually like an interesting piece of
information that was in this dumbass
[ __ ] article
not all influencer brands survive model
and TV presenter Alexa Chung who has
quadruple and Instagram followers as
charnis shut down her fashion brand in
March after five years influencer tati
Westbrook closed her beauty brand in
2021 after just two years see something
Navy seems to be struggling with the
Paradox fit familiar to influencer run
Brands yeah that's definitely a thing so
I didn't really feel like this was that
explosive the thing that everyone is
like latching on to is you know vendors
and writers and models claiming that
they haven't been paid even though once
um
Insider had reached back out to this you
know unnamed Indian vendor he claimed
that his 365 000 Bill actually was paid
so thanks Insider for getting people
paid right also there are like some
models some Freelancers that it took a
while to get paid but they did get paid
it just was like a long pay period there
was a model who still claims that she
hasn't been paid two thousand dollars
and there are like startups are
notorious for taking a long time to pay
people I just wanted to just like big
companies not even startups this is like
startup culture like you will pay a
vendor when you absolutely have to like
that startup culture
um and even enormous like fashion brands
do that like getting vendors paid and
it's not that doesn't mean it's right
but it is kind of like the the way of
working especially in fashion like you
get paid and then you'll finally get
your vendors paid like it takes a long
time
um and so the article starts out talking
about her birthday parties and her kids
birthday parties and vendors are seeing
this who haven't been paid and the
article also like self-owns by saying
like the parties are sponsored and they
were like profitable for the company so
it's not like there's spending all of
this company money on lavish parties the
parties are actually money making things
for the company and I don't know why
they were focusing so much on the
parties when a yes they were profitable
anybody who was watching it on social
media could have told you that it was
sponsored like that's what Don Hario was
a sponsor the kids party was so
sponsored like the whole thing was I
think one company I forget but I
remember seeing it and being oh how nice
to have a free kids party right and so
like the employees in here were
disgruntled that like they were as a
part of their job pitching Brands to
sponsor the party even though the party
was profitable for the brand that's
their job to make money for the brand no
and it literally said that Ariel was
using her personal money to pay for some
of the party stuff and then they would
the employee company would make money on
the partnership side so it's like
Ariel's actually operating on a personal
loss so that the Pump Company can make
money from her birthday party so and and
here's the thing that I found so
interesting it was like you know
there are models out here who like
haven't been paid but then Arielle is
wearing you know two thousand dollar
boots and that definitely doesn't look
great I agree
um but I feel like and the article
really glossed over the fact that like
there was a 10 million investment made
in this company it is not Ariel's
company she is the face of it they even
said she's never in the office wait it's
not her company also I think the most
interesting thing in this article is
that Arielle is a minority stakeholder
now in something she's the face of it so
the the article's thesis is that Ariel's
checked out that's how it literally ends
it's like well would you be checked out
of a company you now own five percent
there's no future for the company
because I don't think there's a company
without Ariel and at the end of the day
Ariel is just over it one like you don't
[ __ ] know how Ariel feels about it
too she's a minority stakeholder and it
like it's up to something Navy now to
spread its wings and fly as a brand
because that launched off her back and
also this article shows how like
influencer Brands can only be successful
If eventually the influencer is removed
from it and someone's just walking into
a something Navy Store who has no idea
what the Instagram account is so it
looks like that's what they're all
trying to do here but now that Ariel not
a part of it no but the thing is the
thing is like people just get obsessed
with like influencers and like want to
blame Ariel because she's rich and like
there's like you know a writer who
hasn't been paid and I'm not saying that
that's right but you have to think about
it like okay she's a minority she it's
her the company was launched off her
back but she's like a minority minority
owner that's like you're like an Uber
employee not getting paid and people
like well Gary vaynerchuk was flying
private it's the exact same thing while
like she is the face of the company it's
not her company a 10 million dollar
investment in a brand that hadn't even
had any sales yet she probably owns so
little of this company
so you we need to get a little
perspective yeah then also Insider is
upset that she doesn't wear enough of
her own clothes and that she's quote
increasingly detached from her own
business People Say More Often
photograph wearing designer pieces like
twenty six hundred dollar memories boots
and a 3900 leather jacket from Kate the
clothing brand other than this
um what's new there isn't that why
people follow her to begin with and why
she gained such influence because like
she has access to the whole thing nobody
ever will you know it's always been like
this
what's the word that I'm always looking
for with an a aspirational aspirational
content so I don't know why everyone's
acting like this is a big surprise now I
completely agree I feel like her thing
has always always been like wearing a
really nice coat wearing really nice
shoes and a really nice bag and yeah
there might be something Navy sweater
under it what sweater did she wear with
the jacket no and by the way that's what
I'm saying about the whole article it's
like okay the company is failing and I
do think part of the reason the company
is failing is because Ariel doesn't wear
the clothes because she wears nicer
things
um again is that newsworthy
I don't understand what in this article
is actually newsworthy yeah and I'm not
glazing over the fact that like there
are remaining like two or three people
who haven't been paid for certain things
and like that needs to be taken care of
and I'm sure that the company this isn't
like the and the article actually does
give good background on who invested in
this company what I thought was really
interesting is the 10 million investment
came from this guy who owned a brand
that did a partnership with Ariel and
they never saw such conversion in their
life and they wanted to get in on it it
happened in a really natural way and I
thought that was really interesting okay
so it didn't pan out how everyone hoped
it would be and the company's flandering
and they have outstanding bills and they
probably should shut down their
operations and just pay the remaining
employees totally
where they should shut down their
operations why like Ariel's checked out
the company's really not successful
checked out I think that's what Insider
thinks about her they don't know her
yeah she's three kids like she I think
that she tries to streamline her work
process in terms like I'm sure something
maybe honestly is the most important
thing to her and like to have someone
accuse her of not caring about her own
brand while like you're supposed to say
like this employee who left and now he's
talking [ __ ] cares more about Ariel's
brand than she does like it's literally
her name and it's being dragged through
the mud I think she loves her brand all
the clothes on the website like whether
you like them or not like they're her
they are a derivative of her style yeah
it's not the Army's version but it's
just something no that's so true I feel
like I remember she once made a headband
that was like she used to wear the Prada
one and hey she made one that's more
affordable and that works I don't think
they need to shut down their business
what I thought about the business model
was so interesting is like they have
opened so many retail stores and like my
thing is like why right like who's
shopping retail and the answer is nobody
but they use this like platform called
leap that like opens up like they they
cover all the absorb all of the costs of
opening up retail shops so it's like
actually not that much of a risk for her
to be doing that and then the article
says you know in one day they sell five
items and I just feel like that's more
of a reflection on an indictment on
retail than on something maybe because
their online sales are strong when
economy is good and the clothes are cute
like everything else is subject to
fluctuations I also thought like the the
way the employees
um at the company like demanded to know
every financial decision it's like
you're not the CEO of this company you
have a job I don't think at a standard
job you would go and talk to CEO well
what are our numbers like so this was
the thing there was not much
transparency about a plan moving forward
or why we're in the position that we're
in what the [ __ ] does a graphic designer
or a marketing person have anything to
do with the financials you don't work in
finance no or why we're in the position
that we're in like not doing well
there's a recession everyone right no so
that's also like I think something that
was I think every if you work in any
industry but specifically fashion which
is in Indulgence I I think you'd be
lying if you're saying you're not
feeling that hit of the economy and
inflation and people are just not
spending money on luxury items like
clothing right now that aren't a
necessity and I think the article really
failed to mention like that's a huge
contributing factor as to why Ariel's
company and also a lot of companies are
struggling right now so I just felt like
that was kind of the elephant in the
room of of part of the reason why
because Ariel say what you want to wear
she's [ __ ] influential and that's why
she got to the place that she is this is
not there are influencers out there who
like launch companies and get people to
invest who are actual frauds yeah who
have followers that are Bots who have
absolutely no influence Ariel is legit
like her and that's that's what I
thought was so interesting that the the
person who invested the 10 million
dollars and started this whole thing was
still Blown Away by her influence she
has influenced she has Cloud so this
isn't like you know smoke and mirrors
yeah they're just struggling for a
variety of reasons but the economy being
one of them right also it was funny in
the article they're like you know her in
her analytics are down from 2021 to 2022
and it's just not as high as it once was
it's like well thanks to this week
that's no longer a problem right I would
love to hear from her like you know what
exponentially what her stories they must
must be triple Jackie I mean I followed
her forever and honestly oh now I'm
singing I couldn't remember last time
she came up in my timeline her stories
now are the first in my for everyone for
everyone for everyone this is also what
I thought was really interesting and you
know Harkens back to my favorite part of
this Story the coven stuff so they
talked about her being a covidiot
whatever
after the Scandal charges took a three
week Hiatus from social media when she
returned she was never quite the same
former employee said the former
high-ranking something neighbor Navy
Team Member said charnis became very
insecure and hesitant to post afraid
that her followers would attack her like
that's so sad she didn't do anything
wrong I would literally die on that Hill
yeah she got coveted she got sick and
she didn't know what to do with it
because it was March 14th so she went to
The Hamptons right how nice for her I
wish that could have been me
also let me see what else I highly
article and they talk about it like
Ariel's rise to um fame fame and
influence and like what people like
about following her they said Ruby that
she likes to show her daughter Ruby they
say Ruby who is now six hold on I need
to find the center the whole sentence
one second
she was one of the first fashion
bloggers to share her life as a mother
discussing postpartum anxiety and
showing her firstborn daughter Ruby who
is now six playing in the bathtub
no that would sound like a really
[ __ ] weird thing weird thing to say
she shows Ruby doing other stuff too it
goes to school Ruby Goes to Camp Ruby
loves to move your bracelets yeah Ruby's
stunning Ruby eats Ruby sleeps
her dog of all like the moments they've
wanted to take and like no it was
[ __ ] weird no I agree also this now
for me like I'm just trying to gather my
thoughts but my main thought here is
like there's 75 of this article is not
newsworthy here's another non-newsworthy
item
high-ranking employees
um complaining uh customers complaining
wait sorry you know customer service
tickets flooding with complaints about
the restocking fee for returns which is
12.75 and inconsistent sizing
okay
thanks
why the [ __ ] did you know this literally
The Tick Tock sound why the [ __ ] did you
have to bring that up no it's like
restocking fee is definitely knowing I
hate when companies do it but it happens
uh literally I would rather there be a
restocking fee than a no return policy
just store credit
that's bordering let's get an article
about that no but I feel like sometimes
like you there's some stores that don't
have returns at all no and then
something Navy responded to that saying
we're a tiny team and it costs us money
and time to restock returns and our
policy transparently reflects this yeah
so by the way that's like a really
annoying thing that happens in fashion
all the time it's not a real chernus's
fault no and like the way that we've
been conditioned as online Shoppers is
you treat
um online shopping like it's a fitting
room and you order a ton of stuff I do
it with the time anything revolve
actually like makes it wants people to
do it like because and that's a part of
their success yes you order a ton of
stuff sometimes you order a few sizes
too yeah and then you return the things
that don't suit you and it has to be
profitable for the company so if you do
it too much they will restrict your
ability to shop with them or return with
them
um but Ariel saying like can something
sorry not even Ariel because this is
something maybe in their two separate
Brands is saying like we can't afford to
do that right they're small companies so
like 20 things that you think will work
and if they don't like you have you can
return them but it's going to cost so
not only is there so much [ __ ] in this
world again like you don't have to shop
there right right there's no gun to your
head so not only is there so much in
this article that's like genuinely not
newsworthy um there's so much stuff that
like they're making out you don't think
it's newsworthy that she pronounced
elements now I'm on that page too okay
that's probably my favorite okay this
page is everything so there's a bunch of
[ __ ] in there that's not newsworthy but
there's also a bunch of [ __ ] in there
that they're making out to be like such
a big deal but that standard practice in
fashion Industries like the restocking
fee like charnis would frequently
flip-flop approving certain Styles one
day and then deciding she didn't like
them after the samples arrived literally
we don't even have a fashion company we
have merch we will spend six months
designing we somebody comes it's so
fugly we're like you know just forget it
that is so common like the fact like you
want to change it no she should say okay
it's ugly but let's leave it because the
sample's here and I don't want people to
say I flip-flopped in Business Insider
it's so [ __ ] stupid okay then
um was the uh the spawn con stuff so I
thought this was so [ __ ] funny I have
it here if you want it okay so
interesting so she had two a bunch of
Instagram Partnerships but two that were
mentioned here with the company vivrel
and the Skin Care brand elemis which are
both very new companies with let's be
honest [ __ ] weird ass names you could
say viverell I think that's what I used
to think if you were Latin you would say
Double L yeah Double L you could say
elimis and by the way I would not know
how to say elements if it weren't for
people like using it on Tick Tock I mean
like if it wasn't for Ariel's choices
Instagrams right so she had two brand
deals that she wanted to post and she
was a little reluctant and like people
had to kind of hound her down to record
the uh viral one because
well here's why hold on hold on
Charlie's hated posting for certain
brands right so they may first an
article they made it seem like she hated
posting for verell because she was like
embarrassed to be you know with a
company that's not like you know buying
purses you're renting sure they said she
didn't want her followers to think she
rented handbags but she eventually
agreed to do the post as long as she was
photographed only with specific pieces
from designers like Chanel and Bottega
Minetta said the former staffer who
discussed about she writes that first
which makes it seem like Ariel thinks
she's too good to rent bags and like
saying like it was a brand that was like
beneath her but then they added a little
thing in parentheses that's actually
definitely the real reason another
employee believed the partnership she
was worried about the partnership
because her followers wouldn't believe
that she rented bags it would seem very
fake uh it would seem very fake unless
it was Chanel and Bottega venetta and
then it's like oh okay maybe she would
rent those bags because that's what she
wears right so she was so it's like the
article really tried to make her look
bad and then really put the real reason
for it in parentheses which is like duh
no one would believe that Ariel charnis
is renting a bag right so I just felt
like that's really that's what you need
to know about the article it's like
they're really reaching for something
because the reason is actually really
fair I can see and I don't think it's
that Ariel tennis doesn't want to work
she's built an amazing business right
it's not like you know what that would
be like me doing you know a sponsorship
with SoulCycle like I'll do it but like
No One's Gonna believe it right come on
so maybe you're finding a way to work
with SoulCycle on a way that people
would believe it and for her that's just
doing Chanel and Bottega and for me
that's eating a donut on the bike yeah
or being like you guys should try
something you know or like me literally
having to go to the hospital after a
soul cycle class yes so okay whatever
also then they said she mispronounced
the names of Brands including vibril and
the skincare brand LMS in videos
according to two former staffers and
elements asset charmness reshoot the
video If I had a dollar for every time I
sent a brand branded content and they're
like you called it the wrong thing or
this is actually you know the two-piece
set not the one that says um this isn't
a pullover it's a half Sim yeah yeah
yeah literally that just happened to me
oh I got once I had to reach you the
whole thing so I wasn't wearing shoes
and it was like it was outfits and they
wanted me to like make outfits which I
did but I didn't put shoes on I didn't
leave my house and they said they wanted
shoes so again this is another example
of like very standard practice ask any
influencer if they've ever had to
reshoot for a brand because they
mentioned something incorrectly or they
didn't use the right code happens
literally all the time so much so that
now a lot of influencers will agree to a
brand deal with a Max of two reshoots
because like it's doing the same thing
over and over and it's a waste of
people's time so okay so she pronounced
two by the way two out of how many
brands does she work with literally a
hundred also like who misprint like
mispronouncing stuff is so related have
you met me go macro also you can use a
brand that you've used you can like have
a brand that you use for so long and
like mispronounce it up until you do the
ad just like you and go macro right you
have them in the office for literally
two years and then we started doing ads
for them and Claudia is like it's go
macro is like oh no it's go macro no I
literally in my daily life was calling a
Goma Crow and then once I did the ad I
learned that I was wrong it's like the
magician so again this is another
instance of like very standard practice
in the influencer industry people get
asked to reshoot things all the time but
now it's like a crime when Ariel charnis
does it right also the employees were
upset because she has a lot of sponsored
content and also they gave the numbers
that if she's doing an infeed post it's
around 20K if she's doing a set of
stories it's eight to 10K and she asks
that in order to most efficiently
utilize staff time and resources she
would shoot multiple sets of content
within a single session so basically
blocking off a day and be like we're
filming everything for this month on
this day which um I guess employees
weren't happy with because they have to
run around and get all the products it
seems like they have to work hard which
uh they didn't want to do but the
article is dragging Ariel because in a q
a she said she'll usually work on
something maybe from 10 a.m to 2 p.m
yeah so it's like Arielle can't so you
have to you're complaining that you have
extra
responsibilities at your job but do you
know anything yeah it's like this whole
work hard not work hard thing right
you're criticizing her for working hard
for asking you for not working hard
enough because she asked you to work
harder right anyways they said then it
says right after that charnis is
apparent aversion to Brand Partnerships
a parent aversion to Brand party she
wants to film them all in one day that's
the immersion management bewildered her
staffers who didn't understand why she
was kneecapping her own business
I can't because she wants to film them
all in one day by the way I do the exact
same thing if I have multiple things to
shoot I'm waiting until today where I
look pretty and wear makeup and I'm
gonna film everything that I need to
film for that week great also lest we
not forget she has three kids I know
what time do they get home from school
no totally she wants to be done for the
day
she wears from ten to two and then she
goes to sleep no and it's like
everybody's always like women can have
it all you can work and be a mother and
it's like well give us time to be
Mother's Day we're dragging someone for
making it work for them trying to
micromanage her schedule and by the way
it's an Ariel turn this is a [ __ ]
business owner this is literally like
she runs her own Instagram account oh
your employees you have literally no
right to comment on how she chooses to
run her life this is her life yeah
also this next one they talk about the
CEO and they don't like how he's like
you know shielding everyone from the
fact that the business isn't doing well
they said he seemed reluctant to respond
to waning sales with measures like
pulling back on inventory or furloughing
employees three former staffers said
instead he relied solely on flash sales
and ever larger discounts how nice he
didn't want to fire people so instead he
got to work he marked down prices no
wait that okay that's another thing in
the article so
okay ready
the employee added that at one point in
2021 even as sales were meager something
maybe spent forty thousand dollars a
week yeah on paid social media on
Facebook and Instagram which ended up
generating minuscule returns and
sometimes even losses okay so they're
trying so what this article is saying is
they're trying they're they're seeing a
problem sales are meager so a solution
that works for a lot of people in any
industry is paid social putting money
behind Instagram ads Facebook ads
Twitter ads things like that so they did
that so they're trying oh wow here's the
here's the takeaway they're spending a
lot of money on the company right no
it's especially after the rumors that
Brandon is invisible for a million
dollars no they're overspending on
Facebook ads want to drum up sales no
because they're trying because the
company's not doing well also what
should they do well they should not
advertise wouldn't that be more of an
exposure on the power or lack of power
Facebook ads you're not getting what
you're paying for because it says also
um something Navy's return on
acquisition spending is consistent with
broader market trends and paid spend so
hey that sounds like an article so it
sounds like once again something Navy's
doing something in the fashion industry
that everyone does no but it sounds like
maybe people are overpaying for paid
social media and it doesn't Garner the
results that they think I'd love to see
an article about that so to me we're on
P it's 21 Pages I'm on page 20 maybe 20.
the most important in my opinion article
no I can't even speak the most important
part of the article is buried at the
very bottom after we get this boring ass
bio on Who Matt Scanlan is who the [ __ ]
cares
former employees said that the CEO
shielded charnis from the company's
struggles Matt was adamant that no one
would talk to Arielle or her husband
Brandon about the performance of the
business if she ever asked about
something you had to say it was amazing
that everyone loved it the brand was
great and sales were great so here 20
pages in we finally learned that Ariel
had no idea that the company was
struggling so badly again she's a
minority owner she doesn't go to the
office because once again she's a
minority owner
um and it was her understanding that
everything was going amazing so she's
gonna of course she had no idea vendors
weren't being paid so she doesn't think
twice about posting her fancy sponsored
party because everything's going great
according to her why was that not the
overarching like to to begin the article
the first page of the article is vendor
is owed 300 Grand arielle's throwing
lavish parties don't you think this
paragraph would have been really
important on page one not buried on page
20 right
right after Matt Scanlan went to NYU who
cares yeah
yeah
also a lot of it is like the former
staffers who are contributing to the
article I think you know in the last two
years she lost 22 employees she has
currently 28 who knows what like how
many employees she aims to have it at a
certain time but it's just like even one
of the employees that they cited who was
like a really high up at something maybe
who's no longer there I actually follow
her on Instagram because she's become
like a little bit of an influencer she's
a mom she has three kids and it's like I
saw how in the last two years she has
three kids maybe that's why she left
right no it's not everybody who leaves a
job is like disgruntled and the business
is tanking no it's so true
um and just to add one more um how is
this newsworthy pull quote the tone on
charnis's personal Instagram has
likewise shifted relatable and smiling
posts has given way but yeah I literally
highlighted the section with and I wrote
has given way to muted underexposed
shots of the influencer hiding her face
behind sunglasses even the way she
dresses now it's just different feels
older and more in the luxury space older
and more in the luxury space but she
added that's not what people were
following her for okay so influencer
changes the filter that she uses
Business Insider writes an article I I
really I don't understand this actually
feels older and more in the luxury space
than when people started following her
because she's gotten older and richer
and richer
anyway [ __ ] article all of this to
say I think that
I'm sure Ariel had a hard week with like
all of the ups and downs of her family
of her family and everything but knowing
that everything that was going around
her wasn't true I'm sure she was just
like so [ __ ] confused but at the end
of the day I think she should thank do
mois because this probably wasn't her PR
strategy but it's an amazing one you
think an article is coming out about you
so you put out rumors that are so much
[ __ ] crazier than what they're about
to say that by the time the article
comes out it's a nothing yeah I don't
know what my my sentiment on the article
would have been if there wasn't this
week left after like nobody nobody this
article drops oh my God crazy [ __ ] over
there no this is and I'm sure it's
actually been a really hard week for
Ariel and like this is not the outcome
she expected but in a very Twisted way
it's the outcome
that is the best possible outcome right
and also I think she's more famous than
ever it also showed how much people are
obsessed with her love her or hate her
like they can't stop [ __ ] talking
they're obsessed with without looking
for a reason for now two three years
people have been looking for a reason to
like really cancel Ariel charnis because
again like I said yesterday she's skinny
she's Rich she's pretty sure life seems
very effortless and everything and her
life is full her life is full people
have been people are so jealous people
have been looking for a reason I'm sorry
and you know what I will literally I
will head to a televised debate with
someone if they can give me a good
reason as to what she did wrong when she
had coveted she didn't know she no
[ __ ] know and she was just going
about her regular life being a business
owner and a mom and a rich one at that
so she has a house in the Hamptons and
and she got to go there and some of us
were suffering in our apartments and
that sucks that's America yeah that's
where we live in so again you have a
problem with like capitalism and
corporate greed and you're taking it out
on aerial charnis and I'm not here for
it I'm not here for it no not at all so
I'm glad that we can close out the week
um and put this whole thing to bed I
think that a lot of the issues that they
Illustrated about sales will be totally
Swept Away by this week's Fanfare I
think everybody's at something maybe.com
checking out what they're because they
say oh the clothes are ugly they're not
selling makes me want to go to
somethingnavy.com and see what they're
selling and I'm sure I'll find something
I want to buy first no it's this is PR
it's like it's really what they say like
there's no such thing as bad press
because I'm sure like this has taken a
toll on her emotionally because people
talking about your family your husband
your kids doing deep Dives like on her
mom's Instagram
it's it's not something that anyone
really should ever go through and so
while it's been taxing and I'm sure
there are a lot of benefits that come
out of it it's still it's still not a
pleasant situation to go through it's
your family I just want to say I'm on
something navy.com like so such gorgeous
things and all things that I could see
Ariel wearing they're in line with her
personal style her style is very simple
and like elegant it's not like crazy
trendy it's very classic yeah no it's
it's not the thing is it's not my
personal style I'm sure I could find
something on that that actually that
green jacket's cute
um
but again not every company is for
everyone yeah
just and again when you're reading this
article like please keep in mind that
Arielle owns so little of this company
she is the face of it it's the same way
I was like okay ready remember when
fabletics was like Kate Hudson's company
yeah it's the same exact thing that was
a perfect example of like building a
brand off the back of a of a famous
person and now I don't even think I'm
sure she still owns like a couple points
on on the company but oh my fabletics
did ship Kate Hudson call me yeah you
know there's a restocking fee right
Hudson don't have a birthday party right
no exactly like we really just need to
get a perspective on her involvement in
this company and the article really
failed to do that yeah an article failed
on a lot of of points I think all of us
as a society like need to look at how we
behaved this week I completely agree and
I think the internet we all we all owe
Ariel turn us an apology like two
because of coven two I've been saying
that for years don't get me started
um we this like we need to use that Tick
Tock sound I'm gonna be real with you
guys you look like [ __ ] clowns yeah
you really do and every single person
anyone like made some [ __ ] up on
Instagram I thought Brittany charnis at
Polo Bar getting arrested shame on you
you're disgusting the person who
released that fake statement shame on
you everyone who acted like a [ __ ]
clown this week shame on you yeah I you
know yeah
also
um all week people were like she's
posting like nothing's happened nothing
is happening because nothing happened
what else would she have done literally
I wonder if she when she saw the rumors
like that were so unfounded like just
the one Brandon charnis invested 45
million dollars if she was like laughing
crying honestly I feel like she's like
has her head on straight I feel like it
actually would have been a relief
because you know with these articles
they torture you like they you know that
the hit piece is being written about you
and like you get an email about it and
they want to fact check and they torture
you and they reach out to every single
person in your life former
College friends roommates and those
people who are still in your life
they'll be like I got this text it's
happened to me like from my friends from
high school
um it makes you sick for weeks and
months on end knowing that this article
is coming out about you especially from
Business Insider which really has no
journalistic Integrity when they've been
like doing this thing recently where
they like pick their Mark and then they
dig through their life for you know two
to six months and they find like all of
the bad things and write that article
even if that night before they'll send
you all the bad things are one percent
of your life and like the 99 like you
are doing so much good mine's day
fortnite article like there was those
allegations from those girls like did
they mention how many small businesses
he saved like they should mention both
no yeah no I think the Deep pornoy thing
like was interesting because while I do
think Dave Portnoy is
not great like likes younger girls I
think there's there's definitely
questionable things in his personal life
I also think his like retaliation
against them really highlighted how
Business Insider has really questionable
um like ethics when it comes to
journalistic Integrity like they just
they have there there is a bar you have
to reach when you're writing for a
publication and and Business Insider
like has a reputation for for not
reaching that bar ever yeah but I do
think like that's not to say like there
were things in that article like not
that everything was a lie like I do
think Dave Porter is like but like he
showed they had like stories from like
two or three girls that like had bad
experiences with him and like he showed
the text messages that told a completely
different story like yeah they told only
a a piece of the story and I know yeah
it's importantly likes young girls yeah
no for sure who wears the story on
Scotty stick right no totally totally I
I completely agree so I just think um
Business Insider like has a reputation
for that yeah but so when when you know
that this is being written about you
like it really it takes over your life
you can't not think about anything else
um and then this week when all these
rumors started to come out I think
honestly maybe it provided a little
levity yeah for her I I think I don't
know I would love her to come on the
podcast like you're always welcome here
early yeah or like someone next time
someone's going through this even though
they won't be able to see the fires
through the trees like
start blogging
documentary drop the Vlog documentary
that's a documentary a celebrity
documentary we need to say yeah just
like the week of my Camp My Week with
cancellation literally
anyways
now
it's over it's over and so everyone take
a look inside yourselves look inward
take inventory where were you
what did you say what did you do yeah
our next story
some allegations worth discussing Nick
Carter has been alleged and accused of
raping an underage autistic fan
so
that's been accused of Nick Carter of
raping an underage autistic fan in 2001
and he has responded to this allegation
denying it but he said uh this claim is
about an incident that supposedly took
place more than 20 years ago and is not
only legally meritless but also entirely
untrue unfortunately for several years
now uh the plaintiff has been
manipulated into making false
allegations about Nick and those
allegations have changed repeatedly and
materially over time no one should be
fooled by a press done orchestrated by
an opportunistic lawyer there's nothing
to this claim whatsoever which we have
no doubt the courts will quickly realize
uh the
um no because I believe it the girl held
a press conference on Thursday in which
she slammed Nick Carter for allegedly
sexually assaulting her when she was
just 17 years old she said quote even
though I'm autistic and live with
cerebral palsy I believe that nothing
has affected me more or had a more
lasting impact on my life than when Nick
Carter did and said to me after he
breaked me I remember he him calling me
the r worded [ __ ]
and grabbing me and leaving bruises on
my arm
she also filed a lawsuit on Thursday
alongside three Anonymous women
identified only as Jane dose who also
claimed Carter sexually assaulted them
wow that was like the most upsetting
thing I've ever heard in my life I'm
like really upset I know my men are
gonna cry and honestly so I saw this
story and it reminded me of a lot of the
things that Aaron Carter alleged about
his brother before he passed away
um and weirdly I only remembered because
I saw In My Time Hop a few days like
weeks ago I had a screenshot of it and
the headline was that Aaron Carter
accused his brother Nick Carter of
raping a 90 year old 91 year old woman
and was asking the FBI to investigate
and then when I was searching that this
morning there's a tweet from Aaron
Carter in September 2019 that said my
sister raped me from the age of 10 to 13
years old when she wasn't on her
medications and I was abused not only
sexually by her but by my first two
backup dancers when I was eight years
old and my brother abused me my whole
life and I just want to say I feel like
we Aaron Carter was like silenced and
wronged
and of course he went through so much
and I I don't towards the end I don't
know like where he was at and what he
was saying but so this isn't the first
time saying someone saying so something
so [ __ ] crazy about Nick Carter like
raping an underage autistic fan and the
91 year old woman and Aaron said that
his brother admitted to the ACT and told
him that quote he covered her mouth so
no one could hear her scream oh my God
um what the [ __ ] yeah and seriously what
the [ __ ] and and Aaron Carter had said
the woman's name at the time I guess
like their mother worked in hospice like
he was giving details [ __ ] he said hey
at FBI my brother raped Mildred and told
me in confidence in his pickup truck she
was 91 years old and my brother told me
he covered her mouth so no one could
hear her scream put me on a polygraph
machine please FBI my mother knows she
was taking care of two elderly women who
were on hospice Mildred and opal who my
mother was keeping alive at FBI what are
you gonna do about that nothing I'm
reporting a rape from Nick on SN on an
elderly woman who was dying and was 91
that he raped strap Nick up to a
polygraph machine and a really good one
please holy [ __ ] like the way I woke up
when you told me this yesterday last
night so the way I woke up yesterday
morning and like I literally couldn't
have cared less about Nick Carter I'm
not even about like I don't even like
the Backstreet Boys the way I will make
it my mission in life to
end end Nick Carter like I will not kill
I'm not that's not a thread I mean like
there are multiple ways to end I will
not stop talking about this now I'm so
upset like right this and to get away
with it for so long and like now like I
I look back and like even I feel guilty
like we all just kind of
discredit Aaron Carter because like he
was like acting crazy and looking crazy
and have the crazy tattoos like but this
was a person like deeply in pain who
like survived years of trauma and who
was like speaking the truth and breaking
the cycle I'm so upset I don't even know
what corner of the story is the more
upsetting two people could you know come
forward with their truth and allegations
and one person's Brave and the other
person's crazy right and and why no
totally
I'm so upset so upset and then it also
reminded me of when Nick Carter was
dating Paris Hilton and she showed up
with a bunch of bruises on herself and
it was said at the time that she had
done that um photo shoot where she was
uh tied up with the um it was like
Barbed Parts it was like chords like um
like cables cables yeah and it I think
the I don't know if Nick said or Paris
said it but like that it was bruises
from that but like there's a lot of
smoke with Nick Carter and it's not your
normal kind of smoke no you know now
that we're talking about it I was being
nice a couple weeks ago I think it's
[ __ ] weird he didn't cancel the
concert the day after his brother died
sorry I'm saying it it was [ __ ] weird
right weird
I was just like maybe he's grieving
because I was trying to be nice no
you're there's something for cocktail
wrong with you and you know what all
these redditors who thought you knew
something about Ariel Turners why don't
you put your energy towards us towards a
Monster yeah towards a real [ __ ]
monster totally I need the internet to
ascend upon Nick Carter these two
accusations have nothing to do with each
other except for the person they're
accusing and they're some of the most
heinous crimes I've ever heard because
it's taking advantage of a vulnerable
person two vulnerable so I could
actually like it is a pattern because
even the ones 91 and 117 and one's your
little brother so three right they're
all
like the same type of Victim Because
they're all people you have power over
and they're all people who come from
like a vulnerable place yeah and they're
like weak technically
um I believe every [ __ ] word of this
I I I [ __ ] I I [ __ ] hate this guy
and the girl Shannon Ruth called Shea is
filing with three other women so now
there's three more four or five
technically Aaron Hospital yeah the
other three and yeah no this is really
[ __ ] twisted and really upsetting
yeah do you want more details or no
like not really like the details of the
tour bus the drink okay like according
to a copy of the complaint obtained by
Page Six the pop star allegedly lured
Ruth into his tour bus after Ruth Shay
that's her last name Ruth I thought Ruth
was okay yeah yeah
uh the pop star allegedly lured her into
his tour bus after a concert in Tacoma
Washington and offered her a red-colored
drink which she now believes was a mix
of alcohol and cranberry juice again she
was 17. he then allegedly took the young
fan who was a virgin at the time to a
bet on the tour bus where he allegedly
continued to sexually assault her
Ruth also claimed in the press
conference that she contracted HPV
um which is a sexually transmitted
infection following her her encounter
with Carter
she said just because Nick Carter is a
celebrity does not mean that he is
excused from his crimes I'm a Survivor
and always will be I just don't know why
why people aren't talking more about
this no like for real let's talk about
it this is this is like a crazy
disgusting story yeah
and honestly I want to hear from the
other BSB members because if someone's
that much of a monster like you know
even if you don't know like details like
you have a feeling about someone like it
shouldn't be that surprising they've
been working with him for like 20 years
no yeah and honestly I feel like the
most honest member of that group is AJ
McLean like I don't know why I'm always
watching interviews with him he's like
we've interviewed him he's obsessed with
his daughter he's uh sober like I feel
actually maybe I think like a lot of his
like dark times when it came to
alcoholism like was like at the height
of Backstreet Boys so maybe he wasn't
like aware enough so maybe he's not the
best person to ask I don't know also
they were supposed to do the back
reports were supposed to do like some
holiday special on ABC and it's been
canceled these claims no I think that's
the best yeah [ __ ] you Nick Carter like
wow I literally just bought us despise
and he was like my I know my number one
I know growing up like I know what did I
know nothing nothing
okay let's get into the next story which
is some positive news is it brought to
you um by Haya yes typical children's
vitamins are basically candy in Disguise
they're filled with two teaspoons of
sugar unhealthy chemicals and other
gummy junk
that Growing Kids should never eat but
that's why Hyo was created the
pediatrician approved pediatrician
approved superpowered chewable vitamin
While most children's vitamins are
filled with sugar and they contribute to
a variety of health issues Haya is made
with zero sugar and zero gummy junk but
it tastes great and is perfect for picky
eaters they fill the most common gaps in
modern child's diets to provide the full
body nourishment that our kids need with
a yummy taste that they love they're
formulated with the help of nutritional
experts Haya is pressed with a blend of
12 organic fruits and vegetables then
supercharged with 15 essential vitamins
and minerals including vitamin D B12 C
zinc folate and many others to help
support immunity energy brain function
mood concentration teeth bones and more
it is of course non-GMO vegan dairy-free
allergy free gluten-free nut-free and
everything else free that you can
imagine it's designed for kids of all
ages and is sent straight to your door
so parents have one less thing to worry
about it's also really fun packaging it
like is this really cute bottle that
comes with all these stickers and like
the kids decorated so you know you'll
get a good 20 minutes of like silence
while they play with the packaging right
and then every time you bring out the
bottle it's like a new sticker reminder
of artwork
um we've worked out a special deal with
Haya for their best-selling children's
vitamin received 50 off your first order
to claim a steal you must go to
highahealth.com toast this deal is not
available on the regular website go to
h-i-y-a-h-e-a-l-t-h.com slash toast to
get your kids the full body nourishment
they need to grow into healthy adults
again that's hayahealth.com toast
today's episode is also brought to you
by Perfect bar don't go nuts this
holiday season fuel yourself with the
perfect bar the original refrigerated
protein bar that is a cookie dough like
texture it is creamy and full of flavor
and it's unlike any other bars out there
now they come in snack size which is
packed up to six grams of proteins and
150 calories a little goes a long way
they're made with the only Whole Food
ingredient and contain no artificial
preservatives perfect bar is stored in
the fridge so grab one after a workout
for a quick bite while you're out or
while you're holiday shopping and you'll
feel good about what you're snacking on
if you aren't convinced already they
also sell non-GMO project verified
gluten-free soy free kosher low GI
everything kosher Ally
um and they're kept in the fridge which
is something I feel like we need to talk
about more because the fact that like
we've like been eating all these like
delicious bars these years that like
aren't in the fridge like ew yeah but
how fresh can they be right it just
shows you how the perfect ones are so
fresh right I love that dark chocolate
one with the sea salt no I know but you
want to know why because I don't really
like dark chocolate unless it's cold
from the fridge it's a little salt yes
the sea salt adds a nice touch I like
the cookie dough one yum yum they're
really good and they know what it'll be
Love At First Bite so for a limited time
they're offering you a chance to try
their refrigerated protein bars for free
here's how it works wow sign up for
email and or texts and then upload a
picture of your receipt from your local
grocery store and they'll reimburse you
for the cost of one bar directly into
your venmo or PayPal account all you
have to do is go to perfect snacks.com
toast to get a free perfect bar today
that's perfect snacks.com toast to get a
free perfect bar today happy snacking
also their snack size ones are really
Perfection those are my favorite ones
they're the perfect size like because
sometimes I'm just trying to tie it over
to my meat rice meal not trying to
replace my meal right but sometimes I am
trying to replace my meal and that's
when I go for the big ones they have it
all when I'm on tour just like being a
mogul perfect bars they perfect thought
of it all they thought of it all are you
gonna miss tour
um yeah well actually we never even got
to like recap how I've been looking
forward to like this special of course
because I'm like I was nervous about it
I wanted to get it over with but also
like I have been looking forward to the
end of the tour it's like a lot of time
away from my house and my family and
um It's amazing And but there's like
some drawbacks like it's just it's a lot
of hard work and I've been looking
forward to it being over and when I tell
you I was not perfect but I was not
prepared for the profound sadness I
would feel when it was over like I
actually on Tuesday night like when we
got home from dinner I had had two
cocktails like I did cry like I was like
it wasn't crying over like pride and
accomplishment no it was like probably
missed the road no not Mr Road like when
I tell you like the material that I
wrote like is it's first of all it's my
it's my life like I don't make stuff up
like it's literally these things that
have happened to me and I've worked so
hard over the last year like if you saw
the first show and then you saw the last
show it was it's so different like I've
worked so hard on my craft and these
stories to like bring them to life and
like make people laugh and like it
really like the material it will live
forever in the special but like it's
retired now and I just feel
um I feel very connected to the material
because it's things that happen to me or
miss the material I'm gonna miss like
you know this part of my life like it's
it will be memorialized in the special
so I'm glad that people will get to see
it but I don't know it's just like it's
end of a chapter it's the end of a
chapter and it's the end of literally
thinking about something non-stop for
one whole year and now I haven't thought
about it and it's like
you know what's there to think about
right you that's so sweet thank you I've
been waiting for you to turn your
attention you're welcome towards me
finally that's sweet yeah Claudia that's
beautiful thanks
we're excited for the special when will
it be out I have no [ __ ] idea cool
cool
stop another person making their big
feature debut Taylor Swift is making her
feature directing debut for Searchlight
Pictures Taylor Swift will be making her
feature directorial debut with search
type pictures the singer-songwriter and
director has written an original script
which will be produced by the
oscar-winning studio behind no man land
and the shape of water and Juno oh other
key details like applaud and casting are
being kept Under Wraps until a later
date but landing the project from one of
the world's most successful musicians is
a queue queue no this is so interesting
like I feel like there Comes A Time in
every like major major pop star's life
where like they do something different
um like with Lady Gaga like she's
obviously really um
taking the acting World by storm like
she's two after seasons in a row back to
back in like Oscar movies and so oh yeah
yeah so I feel like Taylor doing it from
like the director POV is is so cool I
know she's been like writing and
directing her own music videos for a
long time and obviously this is a big
leap um but Taylor doesn't do anything
half-assed like it's gonna be good yeah
it will be I'm so curious like what the
film is about I know it's probably some
type of romance but not like in a corny
way no yeah like a dark romance like I
feel like like all too well short film I
would love that like a All Too Well the
movie
that would actually be really good or
what if it's like a book that she loves
turned into a movie because I feel like
that's what happened with crawdads like
maybe that was her putting her foot in
the water of like writing a song for a
movie for a book that she loved so they
said she wrote a script for it so does
that like that mean she I guess could
have written a script or off a book like
she bought the rights to a book yes
because even when you acquire the rights
to a book like someone has to write a
script right I do feel like Taylor
definitely reads a lot like because
sometimes and I know I sound crazy but
sometimes I'll listen to a song and I'd
like I know she wrote it about a certain
book it says an original script which I
feel like could still be a book no
okay because it is an original script
but like it's a weird way to phrase it
if you're writing a script off of a book
yeah either way I'm here for it yeah me
too I'm really excited I just hate
finding out things so early
but it sounds like plot and casting are
under wraps not unknown it might not be
that early plus if it has a studio
and there's progress being made yeah but
it definitely feels a little bit like
Taylor Swift had the idea today and
we're hearing about it right Taylor
Swift wrote a script hopefully somebody
buys it when the script is done right
yeah that's true
okay but I do think it'll still be like
at least a year do you think she'll cast
her friends and if so which ones like
Blake Lively well so that's the
interesting thing is like
we have so many options or will she use
it as an opportunity to make friends
I don't think she's in that phase of her
life anymore like I think she has like
celebrity friends that like are go to I
feel like that hame girl is going to be
it who was in that movie licorice pizza
and with that change things for you or
not I'm just not like a hang girly Haim
I know I always say it wrong I am they
say it's like
you know like but it does always
surprise me like who Taylor Swift's
celebrity friends are because like we
just found out from Bejeweled like Laura
Dern
in a film yeah I feel like everyone so
there's probably I guess if I sat down
oh a list of 100 actors who are Taylor
Swift Affiliated who could be in it Joe
Owen
I mean they never do anything even
remotely publicly facing together
um no that would be honestly toxic
it could be well it would be a little
unprofessional nepotism and then also
she's gonna watch him smooching this is
not good and she's gonna be his boss no
no right no that could really end up
being a toxic work environment and there
would be like a business inside our
article I'd rather them just see them
walk a red carpet you know they won't do
that because it's like too scary but
they'll play together no I the fact that
they've literally never watched a red
carpet together so crazy could be Sophie
Turner yeah
no there's so many people Zoe Zoe
Kravitz
I think this is exciting yeah for a lot
of Industries combined yeah and of
course the swifties of course but I
think it's going to be like not what the
swifties would expect no this is a huge
pivot like I think it's for the it's for
the critics as well yeah no Taylor like
wants to be critically acclaimed like
she wants an Oscar
and this she could be an egot you know
she has well she has Grammys but like
this is her putting her toe in the eot
mm-hmm
I wonder if she'll be nominated what
were the Oscar songs nominations did we
get the Oscar nominees no us we didn't
no okay because maybe her song for
crawdads will be nominated oh right that
song is actually very good it is and
that movie is so good if you haven't
watched it the holidays are the perfect
time it's a great family film even
though there's like one or two sex
scenes but they're not that crazy
yeah
um our next story is a little more
content news that's exciting and fun for
the whole family wow Beauty and the
Beast a 30th celebration will debut on
ABC on December 15th set those DVRs
Disney friends this is by the way this
is 2022's Annie live like the way we
updated you guys on every single thing
happening in Annie live last year I will
be doing the same because we got casting
news and it's very good so we're mere
weeks from the special Beauty and the
Beast 30th Anniversary television
special that you don't want to miss the
wonderful world of Disney and ABC ABC
it's a new network we'll be premiering
on Thursday December 15th from 8 to 10
p.m on ABC and then the show will be
available to stream on Disney plus now
the castings are here and so you need to
know who is who now Bell the role of
bell will be played by her was an
amazing voice
the role of Beast will be played by
Josh Groban and I just want to have
selected there have been some rumors
circulating about this that I just want
to sort of squash which is that like I
was consulted about this casting as like
a beauty and the beastophile as a Groban
file and no I had nothing to do with
this I actually cannot think of somebody
I would have preferred to play this role
like even
Dan Stevens like Josh Groban is the
Beast wait but it's also perfect because
he's sang the songs on the most recent
soundtrack he's saying Evermore uh as
the Beast yeah Steven says in sing so
they obviously just loved his
performance and he loved being involved
I'm so like I could cry I'm so joyous
yes then Joshua Henry will be performing
the role of Gaston I think he's an
unknown big shoes to fill I don't know
huge shoes to fill and I don't know him
then Rita Moreno will be the narrator
thank you Martin Short will be Lumiere
Perfection like literally if I in my
brain if I could have come up with who
is literally a walking Lumiere
David Alan Greer were because Warren
cogsworth cogsworth he's a Termini Award
winner so he what a Tony Award winner a
too many Award winner must be Broadway
can you show me him do I know his face
um there's not a picture in there I
forget it I forgot it it's fine
forget it click clicky oh he does look
familiar
no I don't know him but cogsworth is is
a really really good role like I think
it cogsworth I would really love love
that role yes and then
um can you get to Mrs Potts Mrs Potts
will be played by Shania Twain
affection Perfection I honestly this is
so Stellar December 15th you can catch
us um watching this on ABC we'll be
together
even though we're watching live with
commercials we're watching live with
commercials I'm so excited like I don't
know honestly
Kayla I don't know what's a better
casting honestly Martin Short or Josh
Groban like they're both literally
perfect yeah like I feel like Lumiere
was literally written off of a Martin
Short character literally and Josh
Groban was literally born to be the
Beast you guys like they better not
[ __ ] ruin this don't [ __ ] it up I
wonder if it's gonna be like every like
the whole story or just the songs like
it's not gonna be Beauty and the Beast
live or anything call it that right is
that what it's called and if they've
been working on this I feel like it's
just a 30th celebration so it's just
gonna be like them singing songs oh I'm
sorry I thought it was Beauty and the
Beast live it's unclear it's that time
of year Annie live was literally a year
ago but we started hearing about Annie
live so long ago okay whatever I love a
30th Anniversary too because when NBC
put together that Wicked 15-year
anniversary it was so [ __ ] good the
two-hour special will be a blend of live
action and animation and will pay
tribute to the legacy of Beauty and the
Beast by showcasing the fan favorite
movie along with new musical
performances designed to take viewers on
a magical Adventure through the eyes of
Belle well Belle is the worst so who's
playing Maurice
thanks let's think like a crazy old man
yikes damn okay that's not really what I
thought it was gonna be never mind
yeah it's gonna be like vignettes
like
that's what I thought it was going to be
but I was hoping I was wrong
well I'm sure this will be nice like a
nice thing to watch with the family edit
to the list better than nothing it's
better than nothing better than Grinch
live right right I mean the bar is so
low speaking of Grinch live are you
ready for our next story is it for the
final Fifth and final oh wow for the
final of the week the Glee dock the
price of Glee has dropped and it
investigates the deaths of three stars
and the show's quote curse the first
trailer for a new shocking docu series
the price of Glee was released on
Thursday giving a first look into the
show's several deaths and Scandals the
three-part ID docuseries will dig into
the behind the scenes drama of the hit
sitcom and investigate the sudden death
of three of the show's young actors
Corey Monteith Mark Sailing and Nia
Rivera quote in May 2009 10 young actors
made their TV debut on Glee by 2020 all
of them would be famous and three would
be dead the trailer explained it's
actually like a good opening it is but
it's like a little harsh I just want to
say like a lot of the Glee people who
like do podcasts and like I've been
doing press have been asked about this
they're denouncing it no they're like
nobody who actually was on Glee has been
consulted it's like there's no one no
directors no actors nobody from the
actual show is a part of it so like how
truthful can it be
yeah
an ID like sounds like it's like a
little
it's like Forensic Files Vibes like yeah
I don't know it's not I don't think I
thought it was gonna be on like
Discovery Plus or something it's not
like the bombshell I think it's gonna be
right and also it's like okay so there's
three Glee cast members who have passed
away since the show came out is that you
know an indictment on Glee and the
culture itself or just Hollywood like
what what's the thread between them all
like not even because naira's death was
an accident it was like it was nature
yeah you know what I mean and then Mark
Sailing was allegedly a suicide and yeah
like Cory Monteith was an overdose like
they're really not connected they're not
connected to coincidence and they have
nothing to do with Glee really they have
to do with like fame fame yes so not
even not even Naya Rivera's no Mark
Sailing and
um not even Mark Stanley Mark Sailing
was like a freak who watched Kitty porn
yeah but there's the death of Uncertain
you know people said like he had
defensive wounds on his fingernails like
that he was a part of some like ring and
he was going to name names because he
was being arrested on these charges yeah
I mean he was gonna like undo like that
that's very like a conspiracy theory
like about you know child pedophilia in
Hollywood I hope they get empty for the
talking Series so because at the end of
the day it's just like a crazy ass
coincidence and that's why people say
like the Glee curse but it's not really
that crazy of a coincidence like you get
famous and you you
fallen in bad circles like where you
know there are drugs and inappropriate
pornography like it's it's more a
byproduct of the culture than the show
yeah so even though
it's a catchy title and it's an
interesting concept like I don't know
that they'll be able to land the plane
unless there's details that we don't
know right because I don't think there's
anything that was going on on Glee
specifically on set no that resulted in
three different deaths for three
different reasons at three different
times in three different years I don't
think it was a toxic set no
I mean like Leia Michelle was definitely
yelling at everyone but like other than
that I feel like people had a good time
on the whole yeah on the whole like I
didn't heard that no I think what I
heard was like they were really
overworked like they were doing 22
Episodes they were going on tour they
were playing at the Nassau Coliseum like
I think they were like young people like
being
worked really hard but other than that
like I don't think there was
crazy nefarious things going on yeah
also they were all even though they're
playing high schoolers like they were
all adults yeah yeah no it wasn't like
chocolate who were you know engaging in
working not being over working for their
like for their parents and and missing
schools they were getting paid and and
they were
real whole people like not kids who
shouldn't be working and if they are not
in these circumstances et cetera et
cetera right
um so that sounds like a big burger
today's theme is like very much nothing
burger like we thought the Beauty and
the Beast thing would be something
that's kind of nothing better we thought
this thing would be something it's kind
of a nothing Burger we thought the Ariel
trying to sing would be something it's
kind of a nothing Burger yeah it's a
nothing burger with whatever sauce
except for Nick Carter
there's meat there
I'm coming for you Nick Carter like I'm
literally coming for you except if
something happens to him like it wasn't
me I'm not a violent person and I meant
more emotionally metaphorically like I'm
coming for your career yeah you'll never
work in this town again updating you
guys on these stories yeah
that's what we can do that's our part to
play and that's our week it was so great
to have you in studio next time you guys
see us on Monday we will be back in our
remote setup which I love so I'm not
upset but it was great to have you here
thank you for coming into town for my
special I know you had like a million
things to do but I know like the special
was the Cornerstone of why you were here
yes it was um and I really appreciate it
and you did Dumont like you really
killed it this week oh my God thanks you
killed it this week we killed it I think
we all killed it this week except for
the people on Reddit who just like made
rumors out of them right who just like
decided to ruin people's lives because
they were bored I would love to see a
Business Insider article about where the
rumor came from and who done it
hundred percent who done it I have
really great ideas for articles if
anybody wants to hire me it's like a
freelance editor-in-chief consultant I
think I'd be great I think it'd be great
too
speaking of great it's been a great show
thank you so much for listening to the
toast the Millennium Morning Show where
we deliver the fast five stories that
you need to know every Monday through
Friday on YouTube so if you're watching
this on YouTube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we have an exciting announcement
coming soon about the thing that we did
yesterday
so that's exciting we're actually just
tease for teasing's sake also I wasn't
here yesterday so I didn't get a chance
to promote the fact for the new episode
of the redheads is out you guys this
episode is so good if you read the book
of course it's amazing we're getting
into everything but even if you didn't
read the book I describe every book in
detail at the top of the show so like
you could follow along but it's our
first episode being all together in so
long and like The Vibes were just
Immaculate the girls are so funny I was
even telling Claudia some of the quotes
from the show yesterday and you were
laughing like redhead Scott jokes got
jokes and then we recap the book and we
talk about the best books of this year
we rate the top redheads books and our
top books of the year like what are your
we're actually gonna do that episode
soon of our top everything of the year
but check it out you guys don't sleep on
the redheads because it is like this
really special corner of the internet
where we're having a good time and
you're missing out so it's never too
late to become a redhead never
ever have an amazing weekend you guys we
love you and we'll see you back in
studio on Monday bye love you bye